I've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am I crazy we don't use that word in
here
[Music]
hi my name is Evita from gate culture in
Singapore how are you Neil I'm good how
are you I'm great thank you for asking
now I'm gonna start with saying the
Matrix such an iconic franchise
um what does it mean to you and what
does it mean now that you're in it I
think the first Matrix really
revolutionized
the way an action movie a giant
Sci-Fi Action Movie can be elevated
in a way that that honors the viewer and
makes them feel appreciated and heard I
don't know of another type of movie that
had done that before the Matrix had so I
think it's incredibly exciting to be
a player within that game
100 now I hear that you have a very
interesting story about your first
interaction with Lana how did you get
involved with resurrections and could
you share that little story you have
about her oh I don't know which one I
was uh originally just sent an email
asking if I would if I wanted to get on
a zoom chat with
uh director
a female director who's currently
working on a project
I said well that's very vague I mean
yeah a little bit more specifics and
they said it's Lana Wachowski and I said
oh wow that's great because I was a fan
of sense eight
um yeah I thought that it was really
wonderfully executed and to be such
super
queer content that was still so
um smart and accessible and fluid I
loved it and so I had a lot of questions
I wanted to ask her so we chatted for a
while I think
half an hour 45 minutes and it went well
and she asked if I wanted to come to San
Francisco and meet in person talk about
this part
and I of course said yes and then that
was probably my Red Bull moment and then
suddenly the mirror warped and I walked
into a world I'll never forget that's I
let you had some references there no but
character though um we don't want to
spoil it for fans obviously but what can
you share about your character like who
is he what does he do what does he want
with Neo I play Thomas Anderson's
analyst
and Thomas is living a in a world as a
game designer where he is feeling
that things might not be what they seem
that he's not sure who he is in the
world and any good analyst's job is to
quell those concerns and make sure that
Thomas
was not asking too many questions
unnecessarily and was able to
um maintain
the Fairly successful and happy life
that he was living I love that do you
want to be my analyst
now I feel like you've probably been
asked this multiple times already but I
just have to know if given the option
would you take the red pill or the blue
pill and why it sort of depends on what
you mean by red pill blue pill
um if I was to be asked would I want to
acknowledge that the world is actually
much more grim and horrible and needed
saving or would I rather happily live in
ignorance that that's not the case I'd
probably take the blue pill but if you
are asking me whether I would rather
seek out adventure and new experiences
and ask for truth instead of a
watered-down reality I would definitely
take the red pill
I won't say I love the answer thank you
so much Neil this is all the time I had
with you today it's been such a pressure
likewise
[Music]